sherry
with lake mead at historic lows most of
us are thinking about how to save water
one local couple doing their part and
also cashing in for their efforts we're
going to meet them this morning it's all
thanks to southern nevada water
authorities turf rebate program which
translates into
cash for grass mary jane bellies is live
now in henderson with more good morning
mary jane
good morning sherry we're actually in
the front yard of wes's roberts home out
here in henderson and wes thank you so
much for joining us bright and early i
mean this is a really unique and
obviously creative way to kind of help
save money really bring awareness to the
community how to save and conserve water
as well as cash in on this program can
you tell us how much money you're saving
right now i think probably 50 to 60 a
month i think i said before i've turned
the watering system off completely
because all of our plants are drought
tolerant if something needs it we'll hit
it you know with a gallon or two of
water but but we went from a lot
to basically just about nothing other
than what we use in the house oh
absolutely and you know this is such a
beautiful mural that you have here that
really matches the golf theme you have
going on right yeah yeah yeah it does so
uh
uh
as i said before that's augusta in
atlanta georgia
uh and and it's just kind of my world
when i come out here and look at it
wishing i was there i know it's such a
beautiful space and i know too that
probably a lot of the neighborhood comes
in and
sits down and well we have people
stopping out front and i'm
first of all going what are you doing
out in front of my house then i
understood they're looking and pointing
at the mural
so uh yeah i mean it's such a great way
to let people know you can save water
but also do it beautifully creatively
and also everything here i can see is
desert friendly it is everything's
drought tolerant and i just wanted
something to soften the the desert
landscaping a bit so that's why we did
what we did that will hurt yeah thank
you so much appreciate it reporting live
in henderson mary jane valesa live and
local now all right mary jane thank you
very much ten minutes past six we're
three days into the new school year but
some parents are still trying to get
their kids registered for class they've
had a delay and it comes because the
district made changes to shared housing
process verification well these parents
say they're frustrated superintendent dr
jesus jarrah says though the district
warned those parents don't wait till the
last minute they have us pre-register
these students for school
and then we still have to turn around
and go up to the school
students schedules are not ready then
they want us to bring in these forms yet
again you know there's going to be some
delays in bottleneck and but i we are
deploying staff there as well to make
sure that we expedite and get our kids
in front of our educators in the right
schools and in their classroom
parents have to have a notarized proof
of address child's immunization records
birth certificate proof of
identification all to be registered for
class we have more details on what you
need to do if you haven't gotten that
taken care of yet eightnewsnow.com day
three all right welcome to the real
world kiddos here we go coming up the
push for the playoffs look at the las
vegas aces back in action plus they're
down but they ain't out
we'll tell you what it'll take to get
paseo verde little league into the
little league world series ah but first
the all-important check of the weather
and
sherry's standing in front of a map that
has a lot of green once again
well yesterday was a very busy day for
thunderstorms across the desert
southwest and we're looking at the
possibility of some of those
thunderstorms bringing very heavy rain
back to the desert where will they fall
we're going to take a look in your most
accurate weather now forecast for your
wednesday it's all after the break we're
live local now
sponsored by centennial hyundai
[Music]
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler
heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now
las vegas wants to bring back the pro
bowl yesterday the lvc va discussed the
return of the nfl's all-star weekend to
a legion stadium convention authority
would have to post a nearly two million
dollar hosting fee and the nfl has to
approve the plans as well i think the
nfl wants to come back here too last
year the pro bowl brought more than 54
million dollars to our economy and
sherry as we discovered high winds at
the cosmopolitan yes
high winds all right this morning the
las vegas aces are in the driver's seat
for the number one seed in the wnba
playoffs after a big win last night
against the atlanta dream well they were
actually down in the fourth quarter but
three out of their biggest three of
their biggest stars asia wilson chelsea
gray and kelsey plum all hit clutch
shots to bring them back aces win 97-90
they host chicago the team that they're
competing with for that top spot they
host chicago tomorrow if they win their
final two games they will be the number
one seed
go aces from football to hoops to
baseball little league style this is
down to san bernardino the team from
henderson paseo verde still have their
eyes on the little world series in
williamsport pa but they got another
bump in the road they lost to utah
yesterday
they jumped out to an early
three-nothing lead but utah clawed its
way back there's the coach giving a pep
talk to the silverity pitcher ryland
gregorich but utah tied it in the fifth
and they won on a walk-off in the bottom
of the six so
paseo verdi's not out of it they play
montana tomorrow at noon our time and
the winner of that game will face utah
for the mountain region championship and
the winner of the region does go to the
world series in williamsport
they play better when it's harder when
it's more challenging well they have
overcome
uh
they've won nine elimination games it's
really incredible yeah that's so crazy
they can do it yes yes they can yeah
small feat and they were nicely ahead
yesterday and then it was like bam bam
bam utah
yeah
overthrew a throw in the home plate and
but you know what that's baseball that's
little league baseball for sure but you
can see it in person if you take the
drive down to san bernardino as long as
the 15 stays open
we got to keep it open yeah we do i
liked your
acknowledgment yesterday what did you
say the strike zone is pretty wide
those are volunteer umpires yes
okay they don't have those it's all good
they don't have any screen they don't
have the case yeah no
6 18 it's a wednesday morning let's look
outside jerry yeah there was some
serious flooding in some areas down into
state line mountain pass in those areas
and we had some big flooding up in our
own mountains spring mountains that's
where we're looking right now the focus
as we look out across the valley we've
got some blue sky we've got some clouds
and we've got a whole lot of humidity
and a lot of mugginess out there but
temperatures are down so it doesn't feel
bad outside and when you got the higher
humidity and the lower temps it's just
kind of a nice trade-off it's when those
temperatures get back into the 90s to
near 100 that it feels really heavy out
there 81 on the strip 76 at mountain's
edge right now picked up some rain south
of mountains edge yesterday about 16
hundredths of an inch but really mostly
just light rain that passed through the
valley 82 at nellis and aliante 79 in
summerlin we've got mid 73 at red rock
80 in henderson this morning
it is the focus of the heavier rain will
stay in the places under flood watches
today and ours has been extended and
that includes all of clark county and
southern nye county which also includes
param paramp you had some flooding
yesterday as well a lot of runoff from
the spring mountains into the park
valley sandy valley at 78 84 in laughlin
right now kingman you could be in for
some big thunderstorms today at 70
degrees right now boulder city at 78 66
up in caliani and again death valley the
entrance is closed according to the
website for death valley so we're not
looking at any way to get in right now
desert radar we are in the clear as you
can see we had some blue skies out there
but let's roll the future cast because i
want to show you as we get into this
afternoon it is indicating that there
will be some thunderstorm cells dropping
some very heavy rain at times nearby if
not in the valley this afternoon into
early evening and then into thursday
more rain indicated around our area with
only slight chances really left
for friday but the weekend also holds
chances for thunderstorms so each day is
a little bit different the pattern is
set up perfectly high pressure over the
four corners and up in northern
california that strong southeasterly
flow with all of that low-level moisture
in place is still with us remember
there's so many areas that are already
saturated it's not going to take much
rain to get flooding to return to areas
like northwest arizona southeast
california and our local mountains so
flood watches have been extended for
southern nevada all the way until
midnight tonight and it's for southern
clark county and all the way through
eastern nevada mount charleston ripe for
thunderstorms again today mid 70s up
there the afternoon hours are the focus
for thunderstorms once we get some
daytime heating you get some lift and
that is the trigger the catalyst for
those thunderstorms so today a 30 chance
about a 10 chance thursday into friday
that goes up a little bit again and
we'll keep chances in the daytime
afternoon early evening hours right
through your weekend highs nicely below
normal in the 90s all right let's see
what's going on on the road fairly
normal which is good news you're trying
to get out the door safely before 6 30.
unlike yesterday when we had those
horrible fatal crashes your crash free
here in town that's a different story
outside of town we'll start with the big
squeeze now the traffic map is showing
some crowded road on that flyover ramp
from the south 15 taking on to the south
95 in the spaghetti bowl but our live
camera showing there's nobody there now
this is the ramp from the north 15 to
the north 95 okay there's a big rig
taking that ramp but let's talk about
the complete shutdown of the i-15
outside of town so not here in town
people driving from mesquite trying to
get into las vegas you're going to have
to wait although it looks like they're
making progress a little bit hard to
tell there but the regional
transportation commission folks tell us
a tractor trailer rolled over caught
fire and spilled its load they got crews
trying to clear it right now but it is
still closed hang out in mesquite for
another little while meanwhile a viewers
got a question about one of the many
freeway road projects around the valley
that story's next in what's driving you
crazy on good day las vegas live local
now
[Music]
incredible pizza company
coming up on 6 26 on your wednesday
morning got a viewer question about the
ongoing work at the speedway bowl
technically known as the i-15 north
corridor project
andrew wants to know when will range
road be done merging onto the 215 and 15
south it's getting bad
and rough
well andrew we know it's been a bumpy
ride in that whole area they're building
new flyover bridges and ramps eventually
a much smoother easier connection
between the 15 and the 215 northern
beltway now the original timeline from
the nevada department of transportation
was for all that to be wrapped up by the
end of this year but that was before the
pandemic so we'll be checking with the
folks at n-dots if they have any updates
thanks for writing buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at eight
news now dot com just ahead gas prices
are still dropping and
another edition of vegas drives we're
headed out to spring mountain ranch
state park how you can enjoy a picnic
and local theater all summer long and
real quickly before we go to break a
live look at the clouds over red rock a
live picture on good day las vegas live
local now
between 11 a.m and 7 p.m in summer
good morning now on good day more monkey
pox cases found in clark county what
health officials are doing to try and
increase vaccine supplies plus cash for
grass how much money one henderson
couple made after they traded in their
real grass for the fake stuff and we're
hitting the road just 20 minutes out of
town but man is it a world away find out
where we're headed in this week's
edition of vegas drives good day in las
vegas it starts right now
now
this is good day las vegas live local
now and hopefully driving somewhere that
has open roads and there was no flooding
yeah i know it's unfortunate death
valley has had been so damaged by the
storms because such a beautiful place to
visit and i love going on road trips
sherry so you gotta set up pick and
choose where you're going if you're
going out of town and you have to plan
ahead and make sure you're listening to
the forecast to make sure that you know
what could be out there but because it
looks beautiful right now but the
afternoon could look very very different
that's like for folks yesterday as they
were headed south on i-15 headed for
state line didn't quite make it in the
afternoon hours thanks to this mother
nature dropping some very heavy rain
down between gene and mountain pass with
prim right in the middle heavy rain
flooding the roads there and southbound
traffic diverted off of i-15 as nhp was
closing the road for a while there until
the water settled even chp california
highway patrol reported a car spun out
and flipped a few times over onto i-15
in in california because of the wet
slick roads there were injuries with
that crash we have got a beautiful
morning out there it is muggy out there
gorgeous few lenticular clouds over the
mountains right now that's wind buffeted
up in the higher atmosphere but down
here in the valley winds are very very
light it's just soupy it is muggy out
there even with 70s and low 80s it's
just a lot of moisture in the air that's
after all those big thunderstorms that
moved in through the area right now it's
pretty quiet the radar is very quiet but
yesterday thunderstorms were flaring up
lots of lightning a little bit of rain
in the valley but the bigger stuff was
outside the valley today is a different
day every day is a little different so
muggy this morning kiddos with 80 as an
average temper this afternoon back into
some upper 90s chance of thunderstorms
again just as that afternoon bell is
ringing please watch the skies be
careful lightning in the area and strong
gusty winds could be with these
thunderstorms again today 6 32 good
morning nate let's check the roads good
morning sherry want to make sure that
we're keeping an eye on the roads for
you especially they're dry right now but
obviously wet road's going to be a
problem freeways are generally crash
free there's a crash up near the
centennial bowl it is not on the 215
beltway but on the on-ramp to get onto
the eastbound side of the northern 215
beltway from durango doesn't look good a
pickup truck into the utility pole there
with another car crashed into the curb
and another one further ahead it looks
like all the ramps are able to be used
but a lot of flashing lights there and
definitely some problems speaking of
problems hey you cannot get into the las
vegas valley from mesquite just yet at 3
30 this morning the regional
transportation commission tells us that
a tractor-trailer rolled over caught
fire and spilled its load on the roadway
so here are the trucks it looks like
they have gotten it all cleared out and
a three-hour long backup of
tractor-trailer traffic and other cars
of course finally started to get through
there so you may be able to get through
but i i'd still wait out a little while
there at mesquite for that to loosen up
john heather yeah if you can certainly
nate thank you cases of monkey pucks in
the valley have doubled southern nevada
health district now reporting 50 cases
here in clark county and investigations
and contact tracing efforts they are
underway now a reminder the online
vaccine appointment system it's up and
running again so you can make
appointments to get the either the
chronovirus vaccine or if you're
eligible the monkeypox vaccinations you
can also check on your routine shots we
have a link to all of this at
eightnewsnow.com and due to the low
supply of monkey pox vaccine the us is
now going to be stretching that supply
with just smaller doses so those who do
get vaccinated will now receive
one-fifth of the usual dose health
officials say research suggests that
reduced amount is almost as effective as
a full dose perhaps you have questions
about monkey pox the lgbtq center of
southern nevada is hosting a monkey pox
town hall it's on thursday august 18th
so next week and that'll start at six
o'clock over at 401 south maryland
parkway two sets of remains found at
lake mead recently may in fact be from
the same person clark county coroner's
office is saying this discovery at swim
beach last month could be related to
others found over the weekend both were
found near the same area this however
not connected to the body that was found
in a barrel a few months ago detectives
are working to use dna to solve that
case
it is new this morning a local injury
law firm has tongues wagging take a look
at this billboard it's at the corner of
boulder highway and nellis it is right
across from sam's town so here's what it
reads
injured while searching for dead bodies
at lake mead demand compensation
we talked to stephen park with park
injury law firm and he explained to us
why he paid for that billboard
the world as it is right now is
is depressing we get bad news every day
so why not throw something up that's
going to make people
either give them a chuckle
let them think about something or what i
thought would happen is no one would
even bother to read it and then he got
the call from us
it is important to note though it's
illegal for lake mead visitors to
independently search for human remains
digging at the lake could result in
significant fines or other penalties so
skip that all together have a laugh and
move on yeah odd billboard indeed well
also new this morning the park service
at death valley national park now saying
to expect state route 190 highway 190
within the park to be closed for at
least another week as maintenance crews
continue to clean up after last week's
flash floods they are also reporting on
the website that there are no open
entrances to the park at this time
and look at this stunning new images
released by nasa showed death valley
before last week's flood so
on the left side are pictures taken back
in july on july 11th before big storms
started showing up at death valley and
then on the right side is a picture that
was taken august 7th after flood waters
rushed through
death valley
last week the park received about almost
an inch and a half of rain that's three
quarters of the annual rainfall in just
three hours a whole lot of blue
indicating the water right there through
the middle of death valley great
pictures huh it is it's such an odd
sight we're not used to that cherry uh
las vegas valley of course also
experienced some flooding this is about
two weeks ago
this though there's the damage that
remains outside of one local apartment
complex from some of the wind
this is outside lake sahara apartments
and well it's still damaged we spoke
with one person who lives there he was
one of 16 families evacuated when a tree
fell under the building
i think i counted
eight trees totaled it were down on the
property or limbs of trees that were
down on the property there's been no
amount to the end there there's been no
end to the stress we've just you know
one blow after another take it day by
day
yeah it's been tough that's william
salazar now he reached out to us late
last night and said that the power
inside of his apartment has finally been
restored after two weeks we did reach
out to the complex just to see how many
residents remain without power this
morning
we have not heard back yet sherry
cash for grass one henderson couple is
doing their part to help save water
they've ripped up their backyard grass
they've installed turf it's part of the
valley's con
collective effort to save water and you
can also do your part to help mary jane
believe is live in henderson with a look
at the southern nevada water authority's
turf rebate program we like to call it
cash for grass who doesn't want to get
some cash in their pocket right mary
jane
oh sherry absolutely you know it's such
a creative and unique way that you can
also save money and do your part as well
we're in the beautiful backyard of west
roberts henderson home and just take a
look at everything here it's so gorgeous
and wes thank you so much for joining us
bright and early this morning you did
mention that southern nevada water
authority paid you three dollars square
foot right right yeah it was they paid
us one thousand fifty dollars
and that covered two thirds of what we
did so it was very helpful to us yeah
and i know that with the turf as well as
the mural everything just seems like it
came together so well it's so beautiful
and that was the idea yeah i i want to
soften the desert landscaping a little
bit and we couldn't be happier and the
neighbors as well oh i'm sure they'll
probably come by all the time
yeah they do yeah i actually take
pictures of it oh wow can you tell us a
little bit about the mural that you have
here well it's wall sensations from
phoenix arizona and that's there's
thousands of holes in that and it'll
stand up to very high winds i think i
think it's warranted five or ten years
the sun's not going to damage it
and it just wouldn't be the same
backyard without that to me oh
absolutely and you made such a you know
beautiful way to mesh it all together
especially with the turf too how much
water are you saving
you know we save so much 50 to 60 a
month but we don't water this at all
we went from
watering all the time to zero
and everything here is desert friendly
too even
african sumac trees
we don't water them so we do bottom a
little bit we have our washer out here
yeah but not as much exactly right yeah
so yeah right yeah it turned out very
nice yeah at first let me say thank you
channel 8 for coming out to our house oh
of course and thank you guys for you
know bringing awareness to the community
such a really creative and beautiful way
to save water and also bring awareness
to such an important issue wes thank you
so much reporting live in henderson mary
jane villasa live local now
pretty good indeed there mary jane thank
you happening today